you might recall last lesson we had a
look at a particular kind of number it
started with an S does anyone remember
what it was called yes go ahead sir very
good in fact can I just get you guys to
underneath here make me a little
subheading right sir
now this is a new kind of number a new
kind of number they're a bit weird
because you can't count to 1/3 you could
count 1 2 3 4 5 you could keep on
counting forever and you'd never get to
assert cuz certs come about through
something different can someone give me
an example any example you like of a
surd go ahead 3 ok now I'm gonna take
this number it's not quite a third yet
but there's something we can all do to
it that will turning into I said what
could I do to this number which a poem
is not yet assert to make it a certain
you want to reckon
well yeah so if this sign is the one
you're thinking of right this sign here
it seems to me attached soil often 2/3
um you might think of it in your brain
as a um as a third sign I'm gonna
fine-tune that a teeny bit this
particular one is a square root zone a
square root zone this guy here square
root sign now we know about square roots
because we know about squares you gotta
be careful with those right because
putting this square root sign over the
top of a number it doesn't automatically
turn it into a cert I'll give you an
example how about this guy
here we know that that is not a cert
it's just a regular old counting number
you care with that so far
yep is this guy I said I put that thing
over the top why isn't this asserted cuz
you're right it's not here what are you
ready
very good the square root of 25 is just
regular old five this is not the surd
okay so you got to watch out this square
root sign just slapping it over the top
of something doesn't automatically make
it a surd we mean these guys right I
don't know what this is but it's equal
to about 1.7 something or other okay you
can get your calculator out find the
exact value out but I'm not worried
about that right now
my point is it's got some weird stuff
over here unlike this which is totally
nice and well-behaved okay now why do we
care about these why do we bother
introducing this weird kind of number
we've been operating just fine without
them the answer is because of this I
hope you've made this heading by now and
the date today is is it the fourth it's
the fourth always handy to put your date
on your work it's because of this fear
and this idea this arm this pattern that
we observe in shapes that kind of leads
us to these guys SERDES are important
because they come out of Pythagoras's
theorem
surds are important because they come
out of Pythagoras's theorem now they're
actually important for lots of other
reasons too but this is the reason we
start with them and it's the reason you
met them just last week before we had
this lesson okay so this is where we
came from this is why we went there
because we're gonna go and have a look
at this now to experience this theorem
which some of you may have met before
that's why you have that piece of
cardboard in front of you now I have a
few extra pairs of scissors if you've
got one between two that probably should
do but is there anyone who doesn't have
a pair of scissors on their table at
least don't give you another one that's
okay anyone else yeah throw one over
here just cuz I said don't see one
that's okay you've got one or a
phantastic all right now what I want you
to do is you're going to be cutting out
some shapes with me and in order to cut
out you need to know what you're cutting
out right so here's where we're going to
begin a right-angled triangle any
right-angled triangle now before you
draw it before you draw it just take
note of something if I put your pen down
just so you can take this idea into your
head with them okay we're gonna draw a
whole bunch of right-angled triangles
today okay
importantly I want you to make sure
yours is different to the person next to
you even to the person behind you I
don't you to draw the same one okay so I
want you to be a bit different here
that's the first thing the second thing
is it kind of needs to fit on your page
and we also need to draw some things
around this now really quickly I'm going
to show you eventually what we're gonna
draw just so you can cut this out
correctly and I've done this before and
then people say I drew my triangle too
big and I can't fit the rest of it
here's what we're going to do you're
going to draw a by angle triangle it
won't look like this one because
remember you want to make one different
to everyone else's and then you're going
to draw some extra bits on the side like
this these are going to be squares I'm
going to walk you through all of this in
a second but can you see I want to fit
this whole thing on your page yeah so
what you don't want to drew what you
don't want to do is draw a triangle and
make it like this big
like it fits on your page but then the
rest of the stuff will not fit on the
page does this make sense okay so here's
what I want you to do now go ahead use
your ruler and a pencil draw yourself a
right angle triangle make sure it's
different to the person's next to you
and also make sure the whole thing when
we're done make sure it all fits on the
page so don't make it too enormous okay
you do have a whole a4 page so I hope
you make it a reasonable size go ahead
and draw that